Number one asset in business is make the people you're dealing with
Know that they matter you don't want people on your team who are constantly
Insecure who don't want to chase their dreams and cease working with you as a backup
Career to what they actually want to do. This is a feeling it's not it's not a series of checkmarks and goals
I think people define success as as finish lines
Rise and shine. It's an espresso time. What's up believe nation?
It's evan my one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level talent at
Something and I want you to find it embrace it and use it to make a difference
So let's start your day off right together grab your coffee and sip on today's message cheer for everybody
Over to you Mel Robbins
also
If you want to hear what Mel Robbins and other successful entrepreneurs have to say about building confidence
Check out my 2:54 of confidence series
I know that everybody's problem comes down to one pattern you're repeating that you can't see when you set goals
When you have an intention on something that you want to change about your life your brain helps you, you know
I talk a lot about being honest with yourself about what you want
And if you're somebody that's watching this and you have no clue what you want
I'm gonna say that's total bull every day for the next
254 days. I will send you a 30-second two 5-minute video for free every morning to help you build unstoppable
Confidence the link is in the description below
I
Had tremendous expect success in the speaking business
I went from zero never had been paid for a speech to literally the most booked woman in the world in three years flat
Crazy, there's a number of reasons why number one the contents terrific. I'm also a really good public speaker
There's not a lot of women on the circuit, but more importantly I behave in a way
Because I know that the number one asset and business is make the people you're dealing with
know that they matter
Take care of everybody you deal with everybody the event planners speaking bureaus
Everybody has something that they're worried about you get rid of the worry you make them feel like they're important
Everybody wants to be around you because at the end of the day, we all want to know that we matter
So if you do business with people that make you feel good, you want to do more business with them?
And so it's a really really simple thing. I called my philosophy about human beings is just be a fan just cheer for everybody
There's so much success to go around people have really difficult lives
They make things really hard for themselves make their life easy. They can feel great
Give him a hug smile compliment them be generous
Don't be a pain in the like literally it's that simple
When you want people to win more than you want them to win with you
That's when you actually win sit again when you want people to win
More than you want them to win with you. That's when you actually win
I think a lot of times as entrepreneurs we get so caught up in our business. We love our business we wanted to win
We're so mission driven
We want this company to succeed that we look at the people on our team and we want them to be with us forever
We want them to dedicate their souls to the business
But you got to recognize that they may not be with you forever as much as that might be your plan
They may not be with you forever
And it's in their best interest to actually leave you so for me I see things in a parallel path
I see I'm running this line. I'm running down this path here
And when somebody joins my team, we're running this path together and we may run this path together for the rest of our lives
That's the best thing for them
but at some point they may need to jump off and go do their own thing to me to go doing their own path and
If that's the best thing for them
Then I will push them to go on actually do that thing because I want them to win
More than I want them to win with me and that's how I ultimately win
So a quick example story Danny the guy who's helping me with my becoming series you vlogs
Let us stuff behind the scenes. His goal is to become a Netflix producer
he wants to make videos that he sells on Netflix or Amazon feature-length stuff and
I pushed him so hard this past week when we drove up from Boston. I'm telling you gotta write the script
Let's I'll bring some with you on the drive down
We're figuring out what is gonna be what I envisioned as a brainstorming point for him what the script could look like
I'll guilt him into doing it
I found these toys that he really likes in Boston said I'll buy those two toys and if you finish your script by the time
We get home you get to keep them and if you don't finish the script
I will stomp on them in front of you
You have to watch me destroy these toys at you and then he finished his script and it was great
I said okay you finish the script. You're early. Awesome. What's next? Let's do a casting call
That's you can use my space here TV has to do it. You need a factory
Let's find one of my friends who might have a factory that can help you basically doing everything
I can like I wake up
thinking about him and his
Movie and how I might be able to help him do it thinking about location thinking about who we can work with
It's an obsession
Like the worst thing you can do was tell me your goal because then I become obsessed with helping you accomplish it
even if it has nothing to do with my business because I want you to win and
So his first movie it might be on my channel awesome
It'd be an honor like to have the first video that starts his career
it may not be it may not be a fit for what I'm doing and
ultimately
It may mean that he leaves me to go off and become a film producer that we're working together for three months six months
Two years six years ten years or he has to then jump off and go do this path because that's actually better for him
That's great. Like the worst thing possible for everybody is that I force him to stay where he is
That he always wanted this thing
But he feels like he has to stay on this path
where I think a lot of bosses either trash the the dreams of the employees that they have or don't take enough time to
Support them and understand them to help them get to where they want to go
the best thing for me to do is if Danny wants to go off and be that guy is to help him go off and
be that guy and that
Will create a hole for my business now. Nobody will be in that role for what I need ultimately
I'll find somebody who can fill that role and Danny now loves me and it's gonna come back
Right, even though I don't care about what the repercussions are like how it comes back to me
It's not why I'm doing it. Just seeing him win is great
But if you keep helping people win and even if that means they leave your company
I guarantee a good chunk of those will come back and help you in unexpected ways
The Karma becomes super practical and when you want people to win more than you want them to win with you
That's when you actually win. So how do you do it?
Let's get to some specifics number one set up monthly meetings with everybody in your team
Everybody who is the closest people to your team meet them once a month get to know them build a friendship
It doesn't mean you have to be best buds
But what you want to do is create an open environment where they feel free to share with you what's on their mind?
It'll never be a hundred percent people always have a fear of sharing what they're thinking with their boss. Even if you're the most nicest
open-door welcoming person
They still won't tell you everything but you can create the best environment possible
- once a month not just talking about business not just talking about
Did you get this done? And here we're here's how we're doing in this progress?
You might think I meet with my team a lot. I mean with them every day
We talk about all these different things, but it's all business-related
Once a month meet to talk about them talk about what they're thinking about
Talk about what they're concerned about talk about projects that they want to work on talk about them
Number two for everybody on your team. You want to figure out what the most important goal is for them
What are they one of the life?
What is their most important goal right now?
That might change in six months or a year in two years, but right now what's a really important goal for them?
This is what happened with Danny, right? We're driving down the Boston together. I'm getting to know him
I asked him what his most important goal is and he wants to one day one day make this video
That's his most important goal
figure out what that video looks like for everybody on your team and the people
Closest to you if you don't have a team yet
It doesn't matter the people closest to you your husband your wife the people who you partner with your suppliers. What is their dream?
What is the most important thing to them if you understand that then you know how you can help
Me knowing that that's Danny's dream
Allows me to know how it can help him
And if you know that for everybody on your team
Then you know how you can help them and step number three is push them on it
Right all the advice that I always give to you like star get started do something immediate momentum. Let's go. Let's go
Let's go. You can be that person
For the people on your team, if you know what their dream is. You've gotten to know them right step one
You've understood what the most important goal is then step three is push them on it
Figure out what the smallest possible step is for them to start taking action and then help them do it
Hold them accountable be their friend be their support network
Push them find resources find ways to help them out
be a
volunteer like I would be in Danny's movie if he wants me to I'll help him build his set if he wants me to I
Want him to build momentum at some point he won't need me anymore. I'm giving him the push
I'll do things that are I normally wouldn't do things that I'm not interested in just to see him
Win really badly and he feels the love and I know that's gonna come back to me
But you can be that support system for the people on your team and be comfortable with them potentially leaving your business
You don't want people on your team who are constantly
Insecure who don't want to chase their dreams and cease working with you as a backup
Career to what?
They actually want to do like you're not gonna get the best work out of people like that
Where if you are a stepping stone to somewhere else?
That's ultimately for everybody involved when you want the people on your team to win more than you want them to win with you
That's when you actually win now. I've got a really special bonus cut for you
but before that I want to know question of the day who is one person on your team or
In your area a friend a colleague somebody who's around you in your environment in your circle. You see on a regular basis
Who you are going to be that person for who you're gonna meet with them get to know them better
You're gonna figure out the most important goal and you're going to push them on it be their support system
Who is that person tell me their story quickly
These aren't the name names, but tell me about that person what you're gonna do to help them leave that in the comments below
Thank you guys so much for watching. I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in yourself and whatever. Your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for another shot of espresso and enjoy the bonus
Let's pray, so give me go
So, how do you define success
I think successes is
is seeing those around you work to their natural best and
Creating momentum for a vision towards a vision that will last
Beyond yourself. So a guy is driving a bus
For 20 years got to retire
He's on Madison Avenue in New York packed every day as people getting on that bus and getting off. Mm-hmm
He has two kids wife lives in Queens. Hmm
He might call himself successful. Another guy might be vice president of that company who call self unsuccessful
so his success what you make of it, so
It's so this success is defined its success is a feeling it's not it's not a series of checkmarks and goals
I think people define success as as finish lines, you know, they well I ran a marathon I'm successful
The question is a why did you run the marathon? And what happens after you've completed the marathon? Do you just keep running marathons?
What happens if you break your leg and you can no longer run marathons, you know
We said a lot of people set financial goals. I'm successful when I make my first million
Okay. Now I have to make my second million its success as a feeling and and it's the feeling of contribution so you were bus
Driver in Queens if he has decided that his job as a bus driver is to ensure that everyone who gets on his bus
Feels better about themselves because they got on his bus and not another bus and so he greets them with a smile
He says good morning. He says good. Bye
That people remember that that that that ride that they took with him
Versus the this vice president of the company who's made it about himself and his financial goals
he's the one who's unhappy as
Opposed to seeing those around him succeed and those around him go home with a love of their their day
You know because they come to work in his company every day
So I still believe success and and good leadership are about service to others everything in your life happens for you. Not to you
I'm just a huge believer in that and so my baseball dream ended
I had an injury probably gave me a premature end to occur
That would have ended anyways in hindsight because I played with enough great players
That I kind of know there was a gap in just god-given ability level not work
But I think to be the greatest there has to be some proclivity for it and work ethic, right?
And so I kind of maxed out my limited abilities
And so when I got released I ended up moving back home with my parents. I couldn't find a job
I was depressed I spent about a year at my parents house just
Broke in every way financially spiritually mentally physically and I remember my dad came home
My dad had just got sober and my dad said to me. Hey I met this guy at a meeting
I got you a job. You get your ass down there tomorrow morning at 6:00 a.m
Getting out of this house getting a job and I'm like, okay. I have a college degree
You know, I'm being picky for a year watching Maury Povich reruns everyday on TV and Jerry Springer
I go down there at 6:00 a.m. I walk in I said, hey, my name is Eddie might let him here for the job
They're like what job. I remember this vividly, right? And I'm like, I don't know
They just told me you know, and they go
Well, we have no idea who you are. And we don't know what the job is they said. Do you know who's hiring you I
Said I don't remember then they go
Well, then you need to come back and I go to the door and I go wait a minute. His name's Tim
They're like there's a lot of tins and I go well
I know he must be an alcoholic because he was at a meeting with my dad Lester. They go. Oh drunk, Tim
We know Tim right and where I was was a place called McKinley home for boys. It was a group home a
Campus of group homes all my boys were Ward's of the court. They were removed from their family there because their parents were incarcerated
Killed or were molesting them and I ended up in cottage eight cottage eight. I had 12 boys
They were 7 to 10 years old now walk through that door that morning not even knowing what the job was and it
Transformed my life. I mean in an instant, brother
I
just saw these eyes these little boys and they just wanted someone to love him and believe in him and care about him and I'd
Have this big belief that people that go through any dysfunction in their family or abuse as a kid
I think our eyes are different. We just have these different eyes man. And so I could connect with these guys
Mine wasn't as severe as theirs
But I knew what it was like to have that kind of anxiety and that kind of stress and that kind of pressure put on
You as a little boy and I became like their father
I was there with him on Christmas and Halloween and their birthdays and I lived with them and it changed my world
Because in that instant, I went from being this athlete who was ego recognition significance gonna get rich
It's all about me
Always when you're a good athlete you knew this growing up was always
Accolades all of a sudden in that instant it became about serving people
Making a difference nothing like oh this is what makes me happy. Oh, I was actually born to serve and help people crazy
no one that never happened playing baseball and while I worked there two years into it the financial business that I'm in came along and
I started in a part-time and I'm the I was the rare young businessman who approached the business world from a place of service
and giving and not making money and
Ironically the more I serve people the more I made a difference the more I contributed the more I was rewarded financially. I
Didn't do it for that reason, but that's what happened
So that's how I got into the business was actually and again everything that my dad wasn't an alcoholic
He's not at that meeting. I don't get that job
And if he wasn't if it wasn't how guy wouldn't it connected with those boys so all of that in hindsight happened for me
Right and and had I met the financial business before that. I'd have flown out of it
I'd have been about ego making money and when that didn't happen out of left and so it all happened in the right sequence Wow
Altruistic world domination honey Empire right? I'm grateful
I understand why I'm here I think because I am so open I wanted to think and see it's a bloody brief life
All of you have the potential for
enormous
success if you want to know what Gary v-d-j Khalid Oprah and others know about
Empire building that most people miss check out the link in the description for a free bonus video